the pandemic forced las vegas city
council members to hold off on big
ceremonies for the better part of a year
but today they returned
and the council chose chose a special
man for a special honor
metro police officer shane mccolonis who
was critically injured after a
demonstration last
june bianca holman is live with the
story this afternoon bianca
[Music]
last summer officer shay michelonis was
doing his job right here in front of
circus circus
he was actually breaking up part of a
demonstration but he was shot
and paralyzed this morning he was
recognized for his selflessness and
dedication to protect and serve his
community
officer mickellonis's father his
stepfather and metro squad were front
row
at the city council meeting those who
know michelona says he's a true loss
vegan he plays the guitar he loves
hockey
and cheers on the golden knights nick
alone is his work nicolonis worked the
metro's graveyard shift because that's
where he was most needed
councilwoman victoria seaman a daughter
and wife of law enforcement
she named nicolone as the city's citizen
of the month to honor his ongoing
recovery
and support from las vegas we will
continue
to support them with whatever we can do
and we let the family know that
i think with shea you know his big thing
is just
you know support the law enforcement you
know the guys that are out there
you know i mean men and women that do
this job every day that get up and do
this job every day
as you see around the country it's a
fairly dangerous occupation lately so
i think that support is big that means a
lot to him and you know not to be
forgotten
the family credits staff at umc and
craig hospital in denver for his care
that colorado facility is considered to
be the best in treating spinal cord and
brain injuries
and nicolones he's back home here in las
vegas and he's recovering
and his family and his friends right
there next by by his side
as he has the journey to recovery bianca
holman 8 news now